hello everybody my name is marbl and
welcome back to miso okay so we got an
adventure to complete here now that
doesn't mean that things aren't already
going absolutely crazy Bonkers here
because I have a bone to pick with a lot
about this game but it's charming and I
love it so that's all I have to say
about that so what other
other oh I caught you okay oh all right
then I thought oh and I exploded I
thought you needed help I had no
idea okay good for you man oh
rooftop
hello did that lady just jump off she
going to be at the front door I I I I
guess
okay thank thanks welcome back how you
doing how was your trip are you all
right oh no you're not okay so I have a
feeling that that person just jumped off
and she's going to be on the bottom
floor right that's what I would assume
logically speaking no she jumped right
here I I saw it it happened it
happened it happened okay so anyway let
me carry on to other places that I can
actually go and do something about
hello hello shutter Tom you're so
hot samanth don't startle me you always
struck me as tough but I guess you're
really a coward cowards really turn me
on what that still I can't believe
satome is dead
a it ain't my fault I didn't do nothing
wrong it's all me shall you damn it Mis
is going to kill me help me samanth you
help me then we'll save
Mis
together
always huh don't be fool and all me fall
all this happen well you want to save
her would you rather stay here forever
because I don't care what happens to you
lers wait wait up okay I'll do whatever
just don't leave me alone oh all right
don't fall behind yeah yeah okay let's
go all right okay
oh
oh all
right o oh and he's dead oh man thas
stay with
me good he's still breathing I have to
get him treated now I'm carrying him cuz
I'm so strong I'll just stuff him in
here for the time being okay so down to
the infirmary I go I'm
guessing this game is all sorts of
strange I guess they couldn't put in a
follower mechanic so they had to just
get rid of him
entirely hey you are you dead yet all
right
whatever just I'll I'll just I'll just
drop him I just I'll just drop him off
somewhere anywhere just going
to okay I guess here is not where I'm
supposed to take him I'm literally just
carrying this guy
why maybe I can take him to the
principal to the
library oh
no okay that was
fun principal there's a problem you're
not going to help you're you don't care
all right whatever fine okay
so Parts oh three parts
left I'm going to warp to the library oh
I could warp to the student council hey
hey is a boner help Toma please he's my
class
classmate woo this should be good isab
boner Toma stay here for a while the
spirits don't seem to come here yeah
well I can't do that not with this
mysterious man he's just my classmate
tona's not that scary I swear so please
oh well if you say so Samantha is a
belonger trust
[Music]
you is this going to be
okay I don't know okay then I guess I'm
not there anymore all right so that
hallway leads to the looping hallway
there's some more doors up north that I
need to find out no don't do that okay
so over this
way howdy ho neighbor
how H how how you
doing okay then all
right that was just rude rude this is
rude rude lot of rudess emergency Bell
touch
whoa all righty then that connected the
uh yeah that connected that so that's
good I
guess okay all right then so that's a
thing now and it cannot be a thing if I
want it to be so now what do you want
you
douche I do you need something am I
supposed to give you something cuz I
don't know what you want right now all
right whatever so this way led to the
rooftop was there really nothing else on
the
rooftop might have been something on the
that lady the the falling lady what the
hell she just going to keep falling I
guess all right
all right I don't know what I need to do
I think I need to go back down to the
second floor because there must have
been more there that I've
missed
so in here no it's a library again this
was the looping hallway but maybe I can
go through it now there's a creepy
girl damn it maybe if I don't go all the
way damn it it happens anyway
what am I supposed to do I'm just
wandering in
soyes the teacher was in there
oh
ah wait oh God damn it it went too by
too fast what do we got I don't know
what this is I didn't read it it went by
too quickly God dang
it
um it might have said locker key but
then again that might just depend
because there was lockers I remember
there were locked lockers somewhere need
to go find the locked
locker no not that way I'm trying to
remember sorry bear with me everybody
I'm a little bit of a doofus no not that
way must have been on the first floor I
think well okay just rode that handrail
right out my crotch this
one
no ah over here these ones damn it not
ah damn it it's had to
be I know there's got to be one I know I
saw it I did I know I know you're all
yelling at me where it is but I
can't one of these days aha unlocked it
cool I should
[Music]
save okay whoa what is
that me's brain oh wasn't included in
the head I got ripped off with that free
head all right unlocked
it death
no no death okay I thought there was
going to be a whole lot of death but
apparently not okay so I did not know
that that was a thing and as the the
teacher is still wallowing in sorrow but
why did he send me to go get the thing
that wasn't there okay so Adorn these
places this has got to mean something b
a c d d the only thing that I know that
looks like that
is a classro because it's a big grid of
shairs I don't know what you me I don't
know I tried to Rack it together with my
brain but it's not working okay maybe
there was something else outside that I
didn't
find ah there's many more fresh Graves
good I haven't inspected Yoshino and
SE
[Music]
great okay so I'm missing some pieces I
don't have all of them but at least I
can offload them there God what is the
point whoa Your Grave don't
don't
you going
to whoa and I'm dead all right God damn
you damn you
shabushi all right that's just a little
silliness ah he a silly silly sucker
he's a silly silly Billy the grave you
don't know the name of it and then my
grave woohoo scary spooky scary all
right so there's got to be something
else here than I I'm missing some secret
nugget of intelligence that I
require I have no idea unless there was
another Locker that was locked and I
didn't see it I don't think I'm going to
be able to find what I need unless there
was a locker upstairs in one of the
classrooms that was locked I think there
might have been where I found
Toma nope that's a Noma okay never mind
then
so
I don't know what it want from me I
don't
know give me some answers lady get hints
thank you you have to oper up six items
at a certain location to undo the curse
these items are hidden all around the
school do your best to find them have
you seen the first floor Halls
Blackboard what is that code supposed to
represent I suspect it's showing a place
in the school one famous Ur lemit at our
school says if you knock on the first
door of the girl's bathroom hanako will
answer tell is all dry after the spirit
got him he should recover if moisturized
but Sal mrees are cowardly creatures
make a sudden loud sound in a quiet face
and they'll literally faint from
Fright okay thank you for those
information
nuggets
so someone needs
water that's what I'm getting here and
then also the thing about the girls
bathroom so I was right about that code
thing it was probably relating to okay I
I okay hang on I did this I knocked on
the
last gross flush it
yes and with that I flushed away the
evil
okay all right
then that ain't
normal does it uh want to eat my brains
it does don't
it I'm com oh God damn it I got to do it
again what this moaning mtle yeah yeah
yeah I got it I got
it come on I got places to go I didn't
know that a ghost was going to be
friendly or maybe oh she's guarding the
thing in the toilet ah I got it so I
need to lead her out whoa whoa let's
play
and I exploded again God damn it I
didn't expect her to jump like
that I need to get around her to the
toilet I'm pretty sure that's what I
need to do right now that's my number
one priority is getting to the toilet as
quickly as
possible yes flush it's good
yes Kaboom couldn't just open the door
like a normal human being all right come
on you want to you want to dance you
want to dance little girl huh what's
your pattern huh oh you you're a jumpy
ghost huh oh too bad I got this whatever
it is got coins
good all right I'm out of here ooh coins
to put on
desks maybe maybe maybe that's think I'm
might be on to something okay so Adorn
these places with coins ah so hang on I
need to I need to take a photo of this I
need to take a photograph of
this no Focus you
douche oh the wonders of Technology
never again will I have to write
anything down important so I got to find
a a classroom with two desks I think two
front desks two God damn you so let me
let me just save real quick all right so
anyway that's all the time I have for
this episode I will pick this up in the
next one and I will finish this puzzle
so thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you everybody who has
been cheering me on let me know what you
think of this game in the comments below
I actually really like it it's got charm
comedy and grossness so thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye won't you put your soul to
rest that's not very good scolding you
need to really learn okay lady let's get
one thing St this BL it's ugly that
dress oh oh
okay yeah my
feeling where did you come
from what the hell